but one thing you did mention is that
with chutes and ladders that there was a
there was an association affiliation
with cold cast so so you did manage the
sound like you managed to get some sort
of distribution or or you know can you
talk about that how did that come to be
um yeah we just we submitted it to send
email to cold cast and feel like that
they put it online they do a great job
when I series launches of doing
marketing for it putting it on the blog
spreading it through their social media
so you know we got a good amount of got
a good amount of using and hits on it
through cold cast and then we put it on
blip and then after our first season
around then then we threw it on youtube
home without much of a you know we
didn't really try to drive any audience
cause you to but that's because you know
had already done it through through cold
casting and through blip and and and did
you get out of cold cast which were you
were hoping that this are would um I
think so I mean it was it was new to us
so we didn't entirely know like you know
what the expectation was it was just
kinda like oh okay cool I want to have
our show and you know I i think the blog
that they have is is one of the best
things i think that because aaron came
out of that like that was really cool
thing you say to sort of you know they
do a nice job of putting it up but it's
not just like hey this is our new web
series actually write something about it
so i think the one that they wrote about
us was but like the science of time
travel or something like that and so
they'll link to a bunch of other things
that aren't shows at all just like other
things and web and one of those things
happens two feet whatever show it is up
there that they're really and so it's
like a cool article all on its own and
it definitely generates a lot of views i
mean i think there was one day there was
like 10,000 views and like getting to
see that so I mean that kind of stuff
was cool I think yeah so they do they do
a great job with helping you launch but
you know just with any web series
regardless of what platform you're
hosting it on it's really up to the
creator's do to drive people to that
content um and that was the challenge we
have your
I'm finishing our episodes and not
necessarily driving driving the people
there but um yeah it's regardless of
diem of the format that the Creator has
to drive that audience there because
they're not going to show up um just
because it's on a certain format or just
because it's on the web and I mean is
getting on cold cast is that a difficult
thing like what don't know much about
the process like not just really yeah
it's just just you know they just they
want to know that you know you're going
to have a full completed season you know
they have a baseline you know production
value that they look for which is um you
know just like crowdfunding web series
are continuing to get better each year
so that baseline it's going up and up
and up in terms of what's being produced
as a web series and I think you know all
of the webseries hosts are you know
increasing that minimum threshold um too
but yeah they're just they're looking
for quality content that will have you
know multiple episodes up a whole you
know is even harder like a minimum
episode number you have to have no I
don't think so we did it yeah I don't
think it was a minimum episode but i
think they are all narrative though
right i don't think they have any hosted
series or anything today um and then and
then what they have a certain release
schedule as well um they did for they
dip for season one yo yeah so we
couldn't wait it's like every weekday
johnson at a certain time every week yet
every Sunday they would they would go
live and it is already monetization that
comes with it or is it or is it just
like literally just the exposure that to
get out of it there's some but I mean
it's just like the same as it is with
you too brainy of the other platforms
where it's like yeah there is but I mean
you'd have to take a whole lot of hits
or have to be anything more than a cup
of coffee and and we mean we
I've had that conversation with other
web series creators to where it's like
you know at least right now like I mean
yeah the foreseeable future there is
there is a possibility of making a
profit from it but as it is right now I
mean it's really really difficult to
make a profit from from a webserie
something that is put online for free
for people to see um and so you know and
I guess it long as you know that going
in it totally works you know because
it's like like you don't want to spend
as much as you would on feature if if
like what you're going to get out of it
is ten dollars in it because you know so
you just kind of have to be careful of
like what your expectations are and
knowing that like just because you have
something great like you're not going to
get millions and millions of views and
you know like that's not I mean I don't
know if that's happened buddy web series
yet but um but there are some really
great ones out there and some ones that
are really worth watching for sure and
and I think it is a new format that is
growing and there is potential there but
I don't know it's just it's just so new
you